PRESIDENT TRUMP: I WANT EVERY
AMERICAN TO BE PREPARED FOR THE
HARD DAYS THAT LIE AHEAD
WE’RE GOING TO GO THROUGH A VERY
TOUGH TWO WEEKS, AND THEN
HOPEFULLY, AS THE EXPERTS ARE
PREDICTING AS I THINK A LOT OF
US ARE PREDICTING AFTER HAVING
STUDIED IT SO HARD, WE’RE GOING
TO START SEEING SOME REAL LIGHT
AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL.
AINSLEY: LET’S BRING IN
KELLYANNE CONWAY, SHE IS THE
COUNSELOR TO THE PRESIDENT,
GOOD MORNING TO YOU, KELLYANNE.
>> GOOD MORNING.
AINSLEY: SO THAT WAS A SOMBERING
MESSAGE AND THE EXTENSION, THE
PAUSE IS NOW EXTENDED TO THE
END OF THE MONTH.
WHAT DOES THE NEXT FOUR WEEKS
LOOK LIKE?
HE SAID THESE NEXT TWO WEEKS ARE
GOING TO BE PRETTY BAD, PRETTY
PAINFUL FOR  ALL OF US BUT WHAT
HAPPENS AT THE END OF THE MONTH?
>> WE’LL HAVE TO SEE , AND THE
REASON THAT THE 30 DAYS WAS
EXPANDED ON TOP OF THE ORIGINAL
15 IS BECAUSE THESE MITIGATION
TACTICS WORK AND IT’S SO GREAT
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO KNOW
THAT THEY ARE PART OF THE
SOLUTION.
IF YOU STAY SIX FEET APART FROM
SOMEONE IF YOU’RE DOING THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REGULARLY IF
YOU’RE STAYING INSIDE AS YOU’VE
BEEN ASKED TO DO BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND CERTAINLY BY YOUR
GOVERNORS AND LOCAL LEADERS,
THEN YOU ARE HELPING TO SLOW THE
SPREAD.
WE’VE SEEN THE POSITIVE RESULTS
OF THAT, AND AS I SIT IN THE
TASK FORCE MEETINGS EVERY
DAY AND TALK TO OUR SCIENTISTS
AND HEALTH PROFESSIONALS THERE’S
REALLY NO SUBSTITUTE FOR THAT
AND I THINK OFTEN AMERICANS ARE
TOLD, THIS IS THE PROBLEM, THIS
IS THE CHALLENGE DO THIS DO
THAT BUT HERE WE’RE PART OF THE
SOLUTION, SO THE OLD SAYING
PREVENTION IS AN OUNCE OF CURE
THAT’S REALLY TRUE, OF
MITIGATION HERE.
IN ADDITION, AS THE PRESIDENT
GOES OUT THERE AND TALKS ABOUT
EVERY DAY AND GIVES THE PROGRESS
REPORT OF THE REGULATIONS AND
THE RED TAPE THAT HAVE BEEN
REDUCED TO THE EMERGENCY
APPROVALS THE FDA HAS DONE IN A
RAPID TEST GETTING THE RESULTS
IN MINUTES ON THE PLASMA FOR
SOME SERIOUSLY ILL PATIENTS,
AND SOME OTHER APPROVAL,
STERILIZATION OF MASKS FOR
EXAMPLE, ALL OF THESE EMERGENCY
APPROVALS ALL OF THE LIFTING OF
THE REGULATIONS AND RED TAPE OFF
OF OUR HOSPITALS AND HEALTHCARE
WORKERS, SOMETIMES IT TAKES
YEARS, ITS TAKEN A MATTER OF
WEEKS TO THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THAT HAVE BEEN INVESTED, THE
MILLIONS OF SUPPLIES THAT
HAVE BEEN DEPLOYED, THE
THOUSANDS OF MILITARY
DOCTORS AND NATIONAL GUARD, THE
DOZENS OF COMPANIES THAT
HAVE STEPPED UP SOME OF WHO HAVE
BEEN HIGHLIGHTED SOME OF WHO
DON’T WANT ANY CREDIT DON’T NEED
IT JUST WANT TO HELP ITS REALLY
BEEN AN INCREDIBLE EFFORT ON
BEHALF OF AMERICA BUT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AND OUR
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF STANDING UP
SAYING THE NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS
ARE GOING TO BE BRUTAL.
TELLS US ALL HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
THAT WE PAY ATTENTION AND WE
COMPLY WITH SOME REALLY
SIMPLE ASKS.
BRIAN:  MIGHT NOT SURPRISE YOU,
BUT THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT,
JOE BIDEN, VERY CRITICAL OF THE
PRESIDENT’S HANDLING OF THIS
BEINGS AND HE BROUGHT UP AN
IDEA.
HE SAID THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
CALL UP PRESIDENT OBAMA FOR HELP
WILL HE?
>> WELL THE PRESIDENT WAS ASKED
THAT QUESTION.
I THINK IT’S REALLY DISA POINT
ING TO HAVE PRESIDENT OBAMA
’S WHO APPARENTLY DOESN’T
TALK MUCH TO HIM, OUT THERE,
CRITICIZING INSTEAD OF SAYING
HEY, HERE IS WHAT WE DID THAT WE
THOUGHT WAS EFFECTIVE.
WHY DOESN’T VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN
CALL THE WHITE HOUSE TODAY AND
OFFER SOME SUPPORT?
HE’S IN HIS BUNKER AND I HAVE TO
TELL YOU WE’RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
POLITICS HERE AT THE WHITE HOUSE
AT ALL.
WE’RE TALKING ABOUT VENTILATORS
AND VACCINES, NOT BIDEN AND
BERNIE.
THERE’S REALLY NO TIME FOR THAT,
BUT IT’S VERY DISAPPOINTING WHEN
YOU SEE THE CRITICISM.
I THINK THE CRITICS AND THE
NAYSAYERS SEEM SO MUCH
SMALLER AND SHRILL AND PETTY
THAN THEY EVER HAVE.
SPEAKING OF, DEMOCRATIC LEADERS
I HAVE TO TELL YOU SITTING ON
THESE CALLS WITH THE PRESIDENT
AND VICE PRESIDENT AND GOVERNORS
THE ONES THAT LEAK THE AUDIO
TAPE AND TRY TO GET THE
INFORMATION AND GOING ON
THE TV SHOWS INSTEAD OF BEING ON
THE GROUND WITH FEMA AND WITH
THE PATIENTS AND HOSPITALS AND
HEALTHCARE WORKERS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS, I WANT TO POINT OUT
TO YOU SOMETHING THAT HAS NOT
BEEN REVEALED.
THERE WERE FOUR CONSECUTIVE
FEMALE DEMOCRATIC LEADERS, THE
MAYOR OF D.C., THE GOVERNOR
OF NEW MEXICO, FOLLOWED BY THE
GOVERNOR OF MAINE AND THEN
THE GOVERNOR OF GUAM, FOUR
DEMOCRATIC FEMALE LEADERS IN A
ROW ON THAT CALL TWO SHORT DAYS
AGO, THANKING THE PRESIDENT, THE
VICE PRESIDENT, THE TASK
FORCE, FOR PROVIDING INFORMATION
, SUPPLIES, SERVICES,
AND THEN MAKING SPECIFIC ASKS.
BUT THERE ARE NO POLITICS FOR
THEM ON THAT PHONE CALL.
THEY’RE SAYING THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT’
RESPONSE, HERE IS WHAT MY STATE,
MY TERRITORY, THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA NEEDS NEXT, THANKING
FOR THE 29 EMERGENCY DISASTER
DECLARATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
APPROVED THANKING FOR THE
TITLE 32 APPROVALS,
THANKING THE FACT THAT WE’VE GOT
, WE’RE CONVERTING HOTELS TO
HOSPITALS THAT THESE REGULATIONS
THAT WOULD HAVE PREVENTED CLINIC
S AND SURGICAL CENTERS AND
DORMITORYIES FROM BEING STAND UP
HEALTHCARE PROVIDING FACILITIES,
THEY ARE ABLE TO DO THAT NOW, SO
IT’S REGULATION AFTER REGULATION
, MOVE AFTER MOVE, AND
I THINK THE CRITICS SEEM SMALL.
I GUESS I WOULD ASK VICE
PRESIDENT BIDEN WHY HE CAN’T
CALL AND LEND A HAND AND ISN’T
IT A TIME DOESN’T HE THINK HE
WOULD DO BETTER BY CALLING HERE
TRYING TO HELP BUT REALLY WHAT
WOULD HE SAY?
WHAT WOULD HE HAVE TO SAY, THE
PRESIDENT, OUR PRESIDENTS
MADE VERY CLEAR THAT HE FEELS
THAT WE INHERITED A BAD AND
BROKEN SYSTEM, AND THAT’S TRUE.
I MEAN, THE TESTING ECHOSYSTEM
AND THE SURGE OF SUPPLIES WE’VE
BEEN ABLE TO DO IN SHORT TIME IS
IMPRESSIVE BUT IT NEEDS TO
CONTINUE BECAUSE PEOPLE STILL
NEED SUPPLIES, TESTING 1.1 OR
1.2 MILLION PEOPLE PARTICULAR
HEALTHCARE WORKERS OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS, BUT MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE WHO NEED A TEST, WHO HAVE
THE SYMPTOMS WHO HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS SAID YOU SHOULD
GET A TEST ARE GETTING THAT TEST
AND THERE WAS A FANTASTIC JOB
COORDINATING THAT.
STEVE: KELLYANNE TODAY IS A
TOUGH DAY IT’S APRIL 1, FORGET
ABOUT APRIL FOOLS DAY.
IT’S THE DAY THAT RENT IS DUE
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE AND THERE
ARE A LOT OF SMALL BUSINESSES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT DO WE
DO, THEY ARE STILL WAITING FOR
THEIR CHECKS WHOM AM I GOING
TO HAVE TO LAY OFF AND WHOM AM I
GOING TO BE ABLE TO KEEP.
I KNOW YOU’RE IN THE TASK FORCE
MEETINGS AND I KNOW THIS IS A
BIG CONCERN FOR THE TASK FORCE
AND THE COUNTRY AS WELL FOR THE
SMALL BUSINESS
PEOPLE WHO ARE LOOKING IN ON
THIS WEDNESDAY MORNING.
WHAT’S YOUR MESSAGE TO THEM?
>> MY MESSAGE TO THEM IS PLEASE
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE OVER
$370 MILLION THAT IS IN THE
LATEST PACKAGE FOR THEM, AND
THEY NEED TO GET IN TOUCH WITH
THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION, THE DEPARTMENT
OF TREASURY IS ALSO MANAGING
THAT.
FOLKS DON’T FEEL LIKE YOU’RE
GETTING A HANDOUT FROM THE
GOVERNMENT.
DON’T BE PROUD.
THIS IS FOR YOU.
THIS IS BECAUSE YOU ARE AN
ECONOMIC DIRE STRAIGHTS
TEMPORARILY THROUGH NO FAULT OF
YOUR OWN, AND THE PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PIECE OF THIS IS
MEANT TO SUSTAIN THEM SO THEY
CAN KEEP THE PAYROLL, THEY CAN
KEEP PEOPLE WORKING.
I ALSO WOULD SAY HOW GREAT IT IS
THAT THE NON-PROFITS ARE
INCLUDED IN THAT NOW, BECAUSE
THE NON-PROFITS PROVIDE SUCH
IMPORTANT SERVICES TO OUR
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING DAYCARE,
AND FOOD BANKS, FOR EXAMPLE, SO
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO CONTINUE.
BUT FOLKS ASK THE QUESTION, CALL
IN, GET ON THE WEBSITE, WE’RE
TRYING TO MANAGE THAT, IMPLEMENT
THAT AND SECRETARY MNUCHIN HAS
SAYS THAT THE PAYCHECKS WILL BE
DIRECTLY DEPOSITED OR  SENT
THROUGH THE MAIL TO YOU WITHIN A
MATTER OF WEEKS.
WE ALSO ASKED THE LANDLORDS OUT
THERE AND THE BANKS OUT THERE TO
SHOW COMPASSION AND COORDINATION
AND COLLABORATION AND MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS FORBEARANCE HERE
AND FORGIVENESS FOR FOLKS WHO
ARE TEMPORARILY IN ECONOMIC DIRE
STRAIGHTS.
LOOK THERE’S BEEN THREE PACKAGES
COMING FROM THE HILL TO THE
PRESIDENT’S DESK IN ABOUT THE
LAST TWO OR  THREE WEEKS
THAT HE HAS SIGNED INTO LAW.
THOSE ARE MEANT TO PROVIDE
DIRECT RELIEF TO INDIVIDUALS IN
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE IN
SPECIFIC DISTRESS.
WE’RE TRYING TO GIVE HOPE BUT
ALSO MONEY WHERE THERE IS
DESPAIR, AND THERE WILL BE THE
PRESIDENT SAYS LIGHT AT THE
END OF THE TUNNEL.
THERE WILL BE THE GREAT AMERICAN
COMEBACK.
IT’S NOT TOMORROW OR  NEXT WEEK
BUT IT IT IS COMING AND
AMERICANS WILL BE PART OF THAT
AND UNTIL THEN THANK YOU FOR THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FOR MAKING SIMPLE SACRIFICES,
FOR YOURSELF AND WITHIN YOUR
HOMES, SO THAT WE CAN MITIGATE
THE SPREAD OF THIS VIRUS.
AINSLEY: KELLYANNE THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
AINSLEY: STAY HEALTHY.